c'est un geste qu'il faut répéter sans
arrêt
[Musique]
trouver la bonne cadence pour peut-être
un jour sauver des vies
après avoir fait cette fois les massages
cardiaques je me rends compte qu'on a
besoin de beaucoup de force dans les
bras et le ventre dans une situation
réelle je me dis que ce serait difficile
de faire ça bien
parmi ces 40 volontaires une majorité de
novices
ce sud-coréen de 26 ans a déjà appris
ses gestes au service militaires
obligatoires pour tous les hommes dans
le pays
au service militaire je me prenais pas
ça au sérieux
je me demandais si je reste à m'en
servir vraiment
et je ne réalisais pas l'importance
jusqu'à l'accident
l'accident le 29 octobre dernier les
rues de Séoul sont pleines pour
Halloween un mouvement de panique dans
une ruelle étroite 158 personnes meurent
écrasées
c'est la raison pour laquelle tous ces
jeunes sont venus ici
c'était si choquants ces images
continuent à me hanter même aujourd'hui
pendant ce cours j'y pense ça m'attriste
et cela me rappelle l'importance de
cette formation
ça aurait été que plus de personnes
sachent faire un massage cardiaque
[Musique]
malgré tout cela aurait été compliqué de
sauver beaucoup de personnes car il faut
le réaliser dans les 5 minutes après
l'arrêt cardiaque
nombreux sont les traumatisés et d'abord
parmi les rescapés du drame comme ce
Français qui étudie la biotechnologie à
Séoul depuis août c'est l'une des rares
victimes qui a accepté de répondre à nos
questions
j'étais en plein milieu du mouvement de
foule j'étais bloqué contre un mur et il
y avait quelqu'un qui me donnait des
coups de poing dans le dos et qui me
poussait ça se voyait qu'ils étaient en
colère et ils faisaient ils poussaient
un peu tout le monde et du coup il y
avait d'autres personnes qui poussaient
à côté d'eux enfin voilà beaucoup
notamment dans le métro sont anxieux ou
souffrent d'agoraphobie pendant la
première semaine il y avait énormément
de gens qui sentaient pas bien
qui
même s'ils étaient pas là et même de nos
jours ça ça continue encore je suis un
peu plus méfiant maintenant quand je
vois quand je vois du monde j'ai un ami
étranger qui depuis Taïwan a du mal
quand il y a énormément de monde et même
de temps en temps ils se sont ils se
sont tristes quoi
sans aucune vraiment raison valable pour
faire face aux traumatisme collectif les
autorités ont doublé le nombre de bus
d'aide psychologiques dans 35 véhicules
à travers le pays des centaines de
personnes ont pu bénéficier de
l'assistance gratuite de psychologues
briser le silence dans ce pays
traditionnellement pudique sur les
sentiments
dans le passé nous les Coréens nous
n'étions pas conscients de notre santé
mentale
personne n'allait chez les psychiatres
mais aujourd'hui on traite enfin les
dépressions et les troubles mentaux ce
sont des maladies reconnues
communiquer et pour certains dénoncés
dans cette manifestation organisée par
des étudiants la tristesse a laissé
place à la colère
comme il pleut aujourd'hui j'avais peur
qu'il y ait peu de gens
mais en fait il y a plein de monde
cela montre que nous sommes nombreux à
vouloir la démission du président
c'est manifestants accusent le chef de
l'État en personne d'être responsable de
la tragédie en cause le déplacement de
son bureau en septembre dernier qui a
occasionné un quasi doublement des
effectifs policiers réquisitionnés pour
le président
[Musique]
l'accident est lié au déménagement du
bureau du président
[Musique]
son nouveau bureau est tout proche du
lieu du drame
[Musique]
le budget du déménagement n'a cessé
d'augmenter
[Musique]
et de plus en plus de policiers étaient
nécessaires pour assurer la sécurité du
président
ne restez plus à cet homme pour protéger
les citoyens c'est tellement absurde
environ 700 policiers sont nécessaires
pour assurer au quotidien la sécurité du
président alors que dans le quartier du
drame il y avait que 137 hommes
disponibles ce soir-là pour contrôler
une foule de plus de 100000 personnes
le président sud-coréen s'est excusé et
une enquête doit faire la lumière sur de
possibles dysfonctionnements
[Musique]